hey can we change this up this part
[Music]
two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah coming in
yeah I just want to
win I think now I go for bigger pieces I
say I really like the Cubans I get a lot
of Cubans I just want something that
shine long as this diamonds in it I'mma
wear
it my favorite piece right now my B
Money chain that's from my friend that
passed away it sparked up a lot of
conversations on the
internet I think I'm the first person to
do this link it's called a be link I had
came up with the idea like I seen Isel
Adia he had like a Apple Watch chain and
I wanted something similar cuz he had
like a video plan of his fight in it and
I wanted something similar like where
the flip Grand me and my friend playing
but ice box went and turned it into a
whole phone I really didn't mind it when
I seen it cuz I feel like it was like
new like nobody ever did it like close
to to
[Music]
400,000 this chain I got this from
waffy the picture can spin around this
is like initially when I came the first
time I had a chain like this it was a
memory pen that I got from Wy for like
4,000 but I end up upgrading it to the
memory pendant to this and I got a
updated picture like with how I am now
this like 100,000 100,000
even the only piece I got from anybody
outside of ice box and wa is this piece
right here from Elliot elante the Hall
of Fame
piece around the time I had asked him to
make this I just wanted something like a
big circle chain that's how I came up
with the idea we both came up with the
design together like I just told him
what I wanted in it he came back with
this it's supposed to be like the NBA
finals championship trophy but instead
of a basketball it's supposed to be like
a record in the middle and this like the
biggest cubing that I got I think this
is a kilo it's pretty expensive when you
get this elliante stop they come with a
hefty
price like
400,000 this my Oda pendant I had got a
new logo made separate from my old one I
traded that chain in cuz I a really like
it no more I use this chain to give to
any of my newer artists that I sign now
and it's another 100,000 like
115,000
yeah good por chain this my most recent
piece my latest piece for I grab another
one for a long time this one was like
200,000 I came up with this design I
wanted to use the Purple Heart like for
the soldiers my new album is title Hood
P this like the symbolism for like the
topics of the album you know I got the
microphone I'm trying to be on the path
to be one of the goats I got the uh
handwriting for the
[Music]
Poetry this chain that I got on I just
bought this too actually because this
chain was taking too long and I was
really trying to wear it on my birthday
so I had waffy like hurry up and make me
something in like 5 days so I can have
some new jewelry on for my birthday it's
kind of crazy but
yeah this chain
actually ice box made this chain for me
as a surprise I didn't even know that
they was making this like they wanted to
update my first set with my capillar
chain they felt like this was too small
and that I ain't going to really wear it
no more so they made me a newer version
I love the chain and and I got a full
complete set with it like this ring and
I got a
[Music]
watch this watch I got with this uh Polo
g chain they custom made the watch too
they put blue diamonds down the side and
bezel this was like a 100,000 100,000
even this is my most recent watch that I
just got I got this to match up with my
hood por chain I actually wanted the
purple dial with it it's like a rare
watch you can't really get the purple
dial one it's like
23,000 I got this one with the regular
face instead because I couldn't find a
purple face wash but this one is like
160,000 and it's a frosted
AP this right here a Richard meal with
like factory set diamonds in it bust
down watches is this own separate Market
they'll tell you at a factory set 10
times more expensive and you can get
somebody to make those same type of
watch for way cheaper but if you got the
money just go get a factory set watch
this like a $400,000 watch I got it to
match up with the uh B chain like every
time I go and get a chain I got to get a
watch to match it like so it could be a
complete
set this watch I got on right now this
is another Richard meal this like 27
something th000 I initially had the same
watch but I had a bust down case and I
traded it for this one cuz it was worth
more and I wanted something plain I feel
like Richard M is more like a
sophisticated looking watch in the way
it's like a status symbol like people
who know what's going on like oh yeah he
probably got some good going on
these mying they spell out Polo G I got
these from Wy I originally started with
this ring my lady got me this ring and
I'm like I might as well get the rest of
my names spell it out I had Wy make the
rest of these I think these emeralds in
the middle and uh B guest down the side
these was like all in total like 100,000
in
total I want to definitely get some
jewelry like something that different I
want to really bring back the style of
chains rappers wore in the early 2000s
like the real long chains and like they
have like a square pendant or something
I want to bring that style back I think
you got to wear a specific type of
clothes for that though like big
t-shirts big club we going to end up
doing a part